[Musique]
nous sommes en 1988
mon grand-père est ingénieur et
inventeur à ses heures perdues
quand il veut prototyper que ce soit
pour son travail ou pour sa passion il
doit faire usiner des pièces en métal
commander ce qu'il lui faut en somme ça
lui prend plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois avant d'arriver à un
résultat concluant
la date que je vous ai donnée est loin
d'être anodine car c'est cette année-là
que le monde va voir naître la
technologie qui changera ma vie
nous sommes en 2007 j'ai 6 ans et je
grandis avec cette passion du bricolage
après l'école j'ai rapidement pris
l'habitude de rejoindre mon grand-père
Gérard dans l'atelier familial pour
créer des lampes des systèmes de
communication en morse et toutes sortes
d'inventions
il faut comprendre que à cette époque je
grandis avec cette passion de la
création et l'innovation
patient que beaucoup de grands-pères
aimeraient transmettre c'est peut-être
votre cas aussi et j'étais émerveillé
par tout ce qu'il pouvait m'apprendre
à 14 ans j'arrive à un point de rupture
avec cette passion je rentre dans
l'adolescence et fabriquer des objets
simples ne me suffit plus
je veux des objets beaux innovants et
fonctionnel
mais alors
comment faire
comment faire parce que pour rappel je
n'ai que 14 ans je n'ai pas les moyens
de m'acheter toutes les machines
d'usinage qui me permettrait d'avoir une
créativité sans limite
un soir
je suis devant le JT de 20h avec mes
parents et mon frère et après avoir
passé en revue les différentes
actualités je tombe sur un reportage qui
parle d'une technologie en passe de ce
démocratiser
alors quel était cette technologie
il s'agissait bien évidemment de
l'impression 3D
et c'est là que je me suis dit mais
pourquoi pas l'impression 3D elle était
là la technologie qui me permettrait de
créer de manière illimitée
alors une fois le reportage terminé
je me suis mis à chercher j'ai regardé
des vidéos j'ai lu des articles jusqu'à
demander à mes parents pour Noël les
pièces qu'il me faudrait pour fabriquer
ma première imprimante 3D
faisons un petit bon en avant j'ai 16
ans et
je commence à en connaître un rayon dans
le domaine de l'impression 3D mais je
n'en reste pas moins amateur
à l'école on nous conseille de faire des
stages pour découvrir les milieux
professionnels qui nous intéressent
déterminer je décide d'aller directement
à la source et d'aller voir un fabricant
d'imprimante 3D
c'est une entreprise niçoise qui décide
de m'ouvrir ses portes et de me faire
confiance pour un stage de deux mois
deux mois devant lesquels j'apprends
énormément de choses que ce soit sur les
filaments de l'impression 3D les
différentes techniques d'impression 3D
ou même les façons dont on fabrique une
imprimante 3D professionnel
ma passion pour l'impression 3D après ce
stage elle n'en est que plus grande
mais
je découvre autre chose durant ces deux
mois je découvre l'entrepreneuriat
et comme l'impression 3D je me renseigne
je cherche jusqu'à n'avoir plus qu'une
seule envie et qu'une seule idée en tête
à lier impression 3D et entrepreneuriat
alors c'est comme ça que 17 ans je
décide de me lancer de créer ma première
société spécialisée dans l'impression 3D
société qui permettrait à n'importe
quelle personne ayant une idée de la
créer ou du moins de la prototyper
donner du volume aux idées voilà ce que
je voulais faire
je découvre dans le même moment le
secteur du biomédical est en parallèle
de mes études et de mon activité
professionnelle je décide de me lancer
dans la réalisation d'une prothèse de
bras pour un ami de la famille amputé
l'impression 3D elle m'a permis de
réaliser cette prothèse et après ça les
événements s'enchaînent le covid arrive
et je me demande comment je peux être
utile avec toutes mes imprimantes 3D
qu'est-ce que je peux apporter
je décide de prendre mon destin en main
et d'aller rejoindre un collectif
d'imprimeur 3D varois
et avec eux on fabrique des milliers de
casquettes visières pour permettre de
lutter contre la crise des masques
encore une fois l'impression 3D elle a
été déterminante et remarquable tant par
sa capacité de prototypage que par sa
capacité d'industrialisation rapide
alors vous allez me dire que
on a atteint les limites de cette
technologie qu'on peut pas faire plus
que fabriquer de simples visières ou
d'industrialiser des petits objets
et bien non et pour vous prouver je vais
vous parler d'un autre exemple personnel
nous sommes en février 2020 un ami à moi
Sébastien est atteint d'une sclérose en
plaques
Sébastien il a des difficultés à se
déplacer et un soir on nous étions tous
les deux il me confie que pour lui la
seule solution pour remarcher un jour
serait d'avoir un exosquelette
alors je cherche je cherche
et je découvre que 76 millions de
personnes dans le monde ont besoin d'un
fauteuil roulant et que si c'est 76
millions de personnes avaient un
exosquelette alors elle pourrait vivre
et marcher comme vous et moi
encore une fois comment faire
comment fabriquer un exosquelette en
partant de rien
bien si on y réfléchit bien on ne part
pas de rien on part d'une idée et c'est
ça le plus important alors on l'a fait
on a créé un exosquelette entièrement
imprimé en 3D permettant à n'importe
quelle personne avec un handicap moteur
de recherche comme vous et moi
aujourd'hui nous sommes en passe de
lancer notre société
d'ingénierie spécialisée dans le
biomédical et c'est grâce à l'impression
3D que nous pouvons nous permettre de
créer et sortir des processus innovants
nous permettront de créer et sortir les
technologies de demain
voilà on peut mener l'impression 3D
l'impression 3D elle est partout mais
elle est surtout là où vous ne
l'attendez pas nous ne sommes plus très
loin de pouvoir fabriquer en 3D un
organe un organe compatible imaginez un
monde où le temps de recherche d'un
organe compatible ne se résume qu'à une
heure
le temps de l'imprimer
cette technologie elle est encore en
voie de développement mais vous voyez où
je veux en venir
l'impression 3D elle est partout elle
est dans le domaine de la mode de
l'alimentaire et même du spatial
on est plus très loin d'envoyer une
imprimante 3D directement sur la Lune
pour pouvoir imprimer à partir de
réguler
un gain de place et de poids
extraordinaire
pour vous donner un autre exemple il y a
deux mois j'ai un de mes fournisseurs
qui m'appelle et qui me présente une
nouvelle imprimante 3D capable de
fabriquer en une nuit les cartes mères
que nous mettons dans nos exosquelettes
savez-vous en moyenne combien de temps
je vais gagner grâce à cette nouvelle
technologie
2 ans je gagne en moyenne deux ans de
recherche et développement grâce à
l'impression 3D
nous ne sommes plus très loin d'avoir
des imprimantes 3D qui seront capables
d'imprimer les objets les plus complexes
un produit cas chez vous vous avez
identifié la panne vous n'avez qu'à
aller chercher la pièce cassée
directement sur Internet et à l'imprimer
depuis chez vous parce qu'il n'y a rien
de plus local que de pouvoir fabriquer
et réparer directement depuis son garage
ou son salon bien sûr je m'adresse au
plus Brico d'entre vous mais vous avez
compris l'idée
imaginez la réduction d'empreintes
carbone de la simple brosse à cheveux et
vous achetez dans le commerce
ce que je ne vous ai pas encore dit
c'est que avec l'imprimante 3D
on peut créer des objets à partir de
filaments à partir de filaments qu'on
conçoit en utilisant des plastiques
bouteilles
vous voyez où je veux en venir vous
voyez la circularité impressionnante que
cela représente
on recycle on imprime et on recommence
alors
nous sommes partis du constat pourquoi
pas l'impression 3D pour finir par parce
que l'impression 3D cette technologie
elle permet de révolutionner le monde
des idées en leur donnant à toutes le
pouvoir de devenir réel
nous tous et toutes qui sommes ici
pouvons parfois penser que certains
enjeux nous dépassent que nous ne sommes
qu'une goutte d'eau au milieu de l'océan
cependant
les exemples que je vous ai cités
montrent combien chaque petit idéal
ajouté amène un grand résultat alors
seul votre imagination et la limite de
ce que vous pouvez faire donc faites
comme moi et donnez du volume à vos
idées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]